like it was not a necessary loss at
least not this way how it happened
yes i think you feel bad uh i know
myself i've lost more than one game
in such a manner and then it's just that
you you know what happens
i guess you also know this feeling
judith here when you come back
uh into your room and you just try
and you just trying to understand why
why did i play this move why did i play
this
that move because i didn't want it i
didn't like it but for some reason i've
played it yeah
did you have this feeling sometimes yeah
that simply things you don't
understand why it went that way as it
went for me it's sometimes just that's
a simply i i yeah i just don't know why
did i play this move i mean i absolutely
cannot reconstruct my
way of you know thinking process before
yeah and
so i guess something like this is
happening now to
uh fabiano because it's really
a couple of his moves are really
difficult decisions uh
uh yeah quite difficult to explain but
okay it's life you know just one game
he's still
doing well in the tournament he's still
in the leading group i mean
in so he still has chances to win the
tournament and tomorrow is the rest day
so yeah of course but uh it was an
upsetting day for him but
actually he's a player who can get over
it even if tomorrow there would be
around and especially with
i don't think i mean still the
tournament situation is still great for
him he started with two classical game
win and then
it was uh one game
uh he he did not win he in the playoff
he lost and then today
well it can happen any time right to
lose against magnus then we had another
interesting game
uh firuza is every day he's making some
interesting messy positions some
creative idea
he had no problem at all in the opening
against aranyan
but in the contrary in the armageddon
game he had huge problems and actually
he could get mated
at some point very clearly i think that
was already
good enough compensation for his game
against magnus yeah
uh i mean it was as lost probably as he
was winning against magnus so i think it
was quite fair
finally the the result but of course
it's a very big disappointment for levon
who
who was uh i mean had a winning position
much more time and everything going his
way and all of a sudden
uh something have happened and he lost
he lost control maybe on his nerf on on
the position
but still uh still he is also in the
leading group
i mean nobody lost his chances uh
i mean for the first place no nobody of
at least from the top four players
and of course with the the system what
we have here at norway chess that with
the classical game win you score three
points
this means that actually even until the
very end
if you're very close in points anything
can happen
and today finally the two-player the
youngsters
they were having the clash against each
other and
as it was a draw in the classical game
both of them finally got the
scores and at the end aryan was somehow
[Music]
uh played better i'm not sure i can say
that but he
whether he played so much better but
somehow he could convert his
opportunities into victory today in the
armageddon yes
so they both scored at least five both
had their chances
yeah and but somebody had to win yeah
exactly so the the standing after round
four is that before the free day the
world champion took the lead again
in this tournament with nine points
and then we are having uh we are having
arun yan with eight point we have
fabiano and
ali reza with tying for third and fourth
and then in the bottom we have ariane
who won
the armageddon one and a half and dion
christophe won
i think for the players of course at the
bottom
they are very happy that they are
finally scored something and then
tomorrow after the free day they
recharge their batteries and they play
better
and in round five i see we are going to
have after the free day
jan is going to play against magnus it's
not
going to be an easy challenge for him
that's for sure there are no easy games
in any round alireza are going to play
with ariane
and fabiano with levon arunian which is
going to be quite
a challenging uh match again i believe
and uh well what what can
what do you want to add something to
this i want to announce
good news to all our spectators that
they can
have a little rest from us for one day
but bad news is that it's not going to
be for too long
because very soon we are back uh
at least i'm back the day after tomorrow
and we will continue
uh coming commenting this tournament for
you which is
very very interesting i find lots of
basically lots of interesting games and
dramas
going on and even the tournament
situation is still
very very unclear so uh
let's have a rest let's let players rest
let us rest a little bit
and gain energy for all those dramatic
turns of
events which we have every day and
follow this tournament come watch our
streams
we will follow together the tournament
from the day after tomorrow the same
time
as usual five o'clock european time
we will we are all inviting you all
again
uh to watch this really really i believe
really exciting tournament
well i have to admit that i really had a
great four days in the first four rounds
commentating with you it's a great joy i
can say it's a great entertainment for
myself and i see that we have a lot of
viewers
who are following us on youtube and
there are
over 100k if not me maybe it would be
even more but
still so we are very happy for the
audience who is
who are following us and who are staying
with us for shorter or longer time
for now i will be not here on round five
because i'm going to have the global
chess festival which i
organize every year annually on the
second saturday of each october and as
the tournament was postponed from the
summer
to this date i could not cancel that
event so i also would like to invite
everybody
to join the global chess festival online
we are going to have fantastic programs
including vladimir
we made a recorded discussion about
his ideas and the deep mind idea
how to possibly change some of the rules
in chess
i also had a great talk with gary
kasparov we have the
three polgar sisters and uh definitely
be here with vladimir and also
i think we are we are of course we
cannot find uh
sufficient substitute to judith but
we will try to have a very interesting
and strong player uh commenting
the day after tomorrow for one day uh we
we are still keeping in secret
uh the name of the player but you'll not
be disappointed
and then from the round six judit will
come back and
everything will be back as
as as you want it to be
so on october 10th on saturday you can
enjoy the
chess connectors experience online with
the festival event
but definitely don't miss out at 5 p.m
together with vladimir and i will be
back on sunday
so enjoy the evening thanks for watching
us
see you bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we wanted to do a historical top 50
of
uh chess players of sort of all time and
to
to do that we are using um the
statistics by
jeff sonax who has created a site called
chessmetrics we've gotten some help from
uh
frank hoffmeister who is a well-renowned
ps historian but then
we have still kind of added our own
touch and
it's always going to be subjective and
there's simply there's no correct answer
i hope you guys
enjoyed and i hope you agree with every
single
ranking because usually 20 public lists
what could go wrong who would disagree
with anything
but yeah it's been it's been fun and i
hope you like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you